the market is all green loving what we
got the news we got from the Bureau of
Labor Statistics today on inflation
um I'm going to explain why that is
we're going to dig into the report uh
first of all we're going to talk about
what the report showed and how that
compared to expectations
um we are going to dig into and do a
deep dive on some of the core components
of the report and talk about why the
market is having such a strong positive
reaction to this CPI report of course
we're going to talk about the market
reaction across market stocks bonds
we're going to get in Commodities a
little bit and I think currencies today
are showing us a very big reaction we'll
talk about all of that and then we'll
talk about the big takeaways kind of big
picture look at what this means in the
big picture for inflation markets the
economy all that good stuff and then we
will talk about what comes next because
of course here on Market takes we are
always looking forward so listen let's
get into the report the headline CPI
showed inflation Rose just three percent
year over year uh for the month of June
and 0.2 percent month over month that is
down from four percent year over year
and point one percent month over month
want to put up here on your screen a
chart so you can just take a look at
what we're seeing so as you see this is
a two-year chart going back to June two
years ago uh June uh back in 2021 all
the way into 2022 and 2023. as you can
see there in 2022 inflation really
starts to pick up and that big peak
right there in the middle of your screen
that is June 2022 that was when
inflation Rose 9.1 year over year and we
are comparing this reading to that so
when we talk about year over year we're
talking about comparing inflation in
June that just happened to inflation one
year ago when that peat when that bar
right there in the middle is at its
highest point and so that's what we're
talking about when we talk about you
know year over year so inflation's up
three percent from that time now this is
the lowest reading we've had three
percent since March of 2021 6.1
percentage points below the June 2022
high so we are a 6.1 percentage points
below that 9.1 percent we saw in June
that Pi Bar you see the top bar on the
top of your screen
um and we are going from we are really
comparing going back to that report now
this was better than expected and that's
why you're seeing a lot of bullish
momentum in markets one thing I want to
point out in all this bullish momentum
and all this excitement is the base
effect and when you're coming off of a
high base well it's harder to go even
higher uh when you're coming off that
high base so again we were at that peak
of 9.1 a year ago when you compare to
that only three percent higher that
takes a little bit of the Shine off but
again really still a strong report and
this just illustrating the overall theme
that we have seen which is inflation
continuing to come down from that high
point that we saw about a year ago and
that's and that's really you know why
we're seeing some of this come down and
I just want to temper that bullish
enthusiasm don't want to don't want to
disregard it don't want to say oh
there's no reason to be excited there's
reasons there are reasons for markets to
be excited and we'll talk about those in
just a moment but I do want to make sure
that we are looking at this with the
proper context and understanding that
back in June 2022 inflation was rising
at 9.1 percent and we are comparing to
that report uh going back a year so make
sure you keep that in mind it could be
interesting now my man Greg dako the
chief Economist at ey Parthenon he said
something very interesting on Twitter
and I want to relate that to you right
now he pointed out that we're seeing
rapid disinflation in his words but
quote the free lunch from lower energy
prices and easing food and goods prices
inflation is largely over and further
easing will have to come from slower
core Services inflation momentum now we
have not really seen that slowing core
Services momentum and what we mean by
that is what's going on in restaurants
where the pandemic really slowed
everything down folks got laid off lost
their jobs they're just now getting back
into swinging things we really haven't
seen workers even in that sector get
back to where they were pre-pandemic
just yet and so we're seeing prices rise
steadily there and that's the inflation
the FED is more worried about we are
seeing Energy prices really turn lower
and and really bring down the overall
impact of the inflation we are seeing a
lot of the food prices that we saw
really picking it up and taking this
Skyward a year ago that's coming off
well so those goods prices now and you
know when we were saying those supply
chain issues that's all turning around
and we're seeing Services really push
inflation higher and that's the thing
that's got to come down and that's what
Greg's talking about uh when he talks
about what we need to see for inflation
to continue moving back toward the fed's
two percent Target remember the fed's
target is two percent not three percent
we are much closer to two percent now
than we were a year ago obviously when
inflation was nine percent but we are
still a ways away and that's what the
FED is gonna have to be concerned about
getting to the hard part let's dig into
this deeper dive a little bit one thing
I want to throw up here on your screen
is a core CPI inflation just a chart of
that so you can see the movement there
now we know when we look at that CPI
chart you see just you know inflation
goes up and then it comes back down here
you're seeing a bit more of that wave
pattern and we saw even a last couple
months where inflation picked back up
unexpectedly uh where you saw a rise in
this core Consumer Price inflation well
if you look there on the right of your
screen that's the lowest report that we
have seen the lowest number that we've
seen since 2021 core CPI came in at 4.8
percent this month year over year and
0.2 percent month over month that was
the smallest one-month increase in core
CPI since August 2021. now you compare
that to expectations for five percent
year over year and point four percent
month over month the core increase was
also about half of what was expected so
even core CPI which had been the big
worrisome effect or the big worrisome
piece of the report is coming back down
now where you see and you see that Char
or that that number there on the far
right of your screen or that bar getting
down below five percent for the first
time since 2021 so that chart really
just illustrating again that overall CPI
is moving in the right direction for the
fed and for consumers we don't want
those prices to keep rising Rising going
up higher or the pace of those price
increases to keep Rising higher so we're
seeing the pace come down even on that
core number and that is definitely good
news listen the big picture is the
year-over-year CPI inflation is now
driven almost entirely by core services
including housing and by food food
prices are still going up pretty quickly
but everything else is coming down and
pulling that overall pace of inflation
down that core CPI year-over-year figure
that's the down point five percent from
a month ago on a year-over-year basis
and 1.8 percentage points below the high
in September 2022. so listen that's big
energy has been a negative consumer a
negative contributor excuse me we're
seeing Energy prices fall when you
compare to a year ago and we're seeing
core Goods now being a slight positive
as in Goods prices what you buy at the
store things you go and get the grocery
store stuff like that those have been an
overall negative as in bringing
inflation further down and we just got
to see that housing piece come down as
well so think about where we were a year
ago gas was about five dollars a gallon
right Nationwide Repro approaching that
five dollar a gallon level if you were
in California you were seeing six seven
eight dollar prices uh and Russia had
invaded Ukraine a few months before and
we had really seen those food prices
Spike uh other supply chain issues were
still plaguing companies you couldn't
get things as quickly as you wanted and
so those orders those prices were Rising
things were taking a long time you
couldn't get new cars there were still a
lot of those semiconductor issues that's
what we're comparing to now we've seen a
lot of those issues kind of go away
we've seen gas prices come down and we
know when gas prices come down that's an
input to just about everything out there
in the rest of the market so as those
prices have come down overall prices are
coming down and we are seeing now we're
at about a three percent at least on the
CPI gain year over year in terms of how
fast prices are rising core services or
CPI Services versus good you've got core
Services Rising about point three
percent core goods were negative point
one percent uh alter the largest share
of the increase again accounting for
about 70 percent of the rise and we know
we've seen real-time indicators of rent
prices going down but we have seen
housing prices going back up that's
going to be a big piece of CPI going
forward and inflation going forward is
what happens with housing prices that's
going to put that Spotlight squarely on
housing costs those new home prices
those existing home prices housing
starts all those things that we've seen
kind of starting to pick back up and
move higher we saw a big blowout
increase in new home sales just last
month we are going to see if that
continues that's something we'll
certainly be watching for here on Market
takes the U.S core Services prices
excluding housing Rose four percent in
the 12 months through June that was the
slowest pace of increase since December
2021 on a monthly basis they were
unchanged or flat the weakest reading
since September of 2021 so listen these
are all good things these all mean
inflation is coming down those prices
that you're seeing at the grocery store
at the pump at the retail store really
everywhere you look those are starting
to come down and not rise as fast as
they have been as they had been a year
ago that's definitely a good thing for
the market and for the overall economy
speaking of the market let us take a
look right now what we're seeing across
the board in the markets uh someone to
throw up here on your screen just the
chart of what we're seeing on wsj.com
you see right there the NASDAQ of 1.35
percent could be a big day for those
tech stocks on the NASDAQ the S P 500 up
clearly one percent uh early on but the
index jumping to start the day as you
see there are a lot of green across the
board want to take a look at bonds right
now because that's what we're seeing a
lot more action you look at the 10-year
treasury note those yields are way down
and we're down well below four percent
we had approached over four percent
moving towards 4.1 percent actually
earlier this week and we have really
clearly reversed that Trend if you look
here in the so-called Belly of the curve
the three five and seven year these
yields around uh the two-year Mark those
have come down down you see the
three-year down almost 19 basis points
that is a huge decline that's where it
shows not just the expectations for the
economy but also what the Federal
Reserve is going to do there's a lot of
movement in this area in the interim
right where it's about fed policy but
it's also about the growth of the
economy it's also about inflation and
we're seeing those bonds tell us hey
people are expecting way less inflation
they're expecting much lower inflation
and that is a really big and a good sign
really for the overall economy because
you don't want these yields up around
four and a half five percent as you see
down here on the six month the three
month so in the short term folks are
still expecting the FED to be raising
those interest rates keeping interest
rates high but after you get out past
about two years you're seeing the yields
down around 4.3 4.1 and this 10-year
note down around 3.89 down about eight
nine basis points right now in the day
that's a big move now I talked about
currencies let's take a look this jump
in the euro is Big the Euro taking off
against the dollar moving up to 111
seven now for those of you who don't
follow the currency markets the euro is
the biggest input to the value of the
dollar really how the Euro moves against
the dollar is how most currencies move
against the dollar and we are seeing the
value of the dollar decline
significantly the value of the Euro
going up to look at that another way
let's take a look at the wsj dollar
Index you're seeing the dollar Index way
down down about one percent and the
dollar has been very strong and that's
been on expectations the Federal Reserve
would have to keep raising U.S interest
rates that inflation was going to stay
high you were seeing that come off in a
major way right now when you look at the
dollar Index and the value of the dollar
overall this is the wsj index that
measures the dollar against about 16
currencies uh from around the world the
US dollar Index that's that dxy that
measures the dollar against I believe
six different currencies the big ones
Euro Japanese Yen the Swiss franc a few
of those and the Canadian dollar of
course uh but the wsj dollar index for
measures against both you're seeing them
moving about the same amount the dollar
very clearly going down now when we look
at Commodities last thing I want to
attack crude oil that's jumping that's a
good indicator of some bullish momentum
you've also got gold up around one
percent you've got copper AKA Dr copper
up in a big way you see moving higher
after we got that CPI report this
morning so as I said these numbers just
illustrating the overall movement of the
markets and we're seeing across the
board green this is a bullish indicator
really for assets across the Spectrum as
we can see so the biggest takeaway or
the biggest surprise I think was the big
significant decline that we just saw
across the board there were no red flags
in this report you're seeing core
Services come down you're seeing the VA
the price of housing which was expected
because again it's a lagging indicator
that's staying high but the Federal
Reserve and other economists expect that
to come down as those newer numbers get
added in we know it takes a while for
the new housing prices to get added in
and that's expected to come in and bring
inflation down even more moving forward
so the big takeaway from this report
report is this there's just been an
overall decline in inflation that's very
good but but but make sure and pump the
brakes we are comparing to a very high
month of inflation a year ago when
inflation was really at its strongest a
40-year high when folks were kind of
losing their minds if you remember June
of 2022 we got that report in July man
folks lost it that was an unexpected
increase and we are comparing to that so
make sure and keep your hat on your head
keep cool don't overreact next month is
really where we will see whether this is
moving in the right direction where this
continues to move in the right direction
when we don't have a big huge very high
month to compare it to or as high a
month to compare it to because we know
inflation kind of steadily decline
rather than just falling off a cliff
immediately after June but we are
comparing to an incredibly High month
with incredibly High inflation and
that's a big part of why this report
looks so strong today so what to look
for next well let's watch those Services
indicators right indicators of the
services economy we'll look for things
like uh PMI reports those purchasing
managers index reports that come out
from The Institute of Supply management
and the s p uh SMP s p Global right
those are going to be out later this
month those are going to tell us what's
going on specifically in the services
industry what's going on at restaurants
bars Barbers lawyers what are folks in
that economy doing we will see those
reports later on you're going to want to
watch for those also you're going to
want to watch real-time indicators Banks
like JPMorgan City Wells Fargo they
track these closely they put out reports
they'll tell you whether reservations
are being made whether prices are rising
what's going on with prices of a bottle
of beer at the bar what's going on with
those things you'll go you'll want to
watch out for those the FED will
certainly be watching out for those
coming forward that's going to tell us
what's next for inflation what's next
for us well we will be back here on
Monday doing Market takes looking
forward to that week Bank earnings are
out on Friday we will get reports from
JPMorgan Citigroup and Wells Fargo there
going to tell us a lot about the economy
and of course there will be questions
about what this CPI report if it matches
up with what they're seeing in their
debit and credit card data so we have a
lot to learn this Friday from those
earnings reports also as we look forward
to next week we got a lot more reports
we're going to tell you what earnings
report to watch out earnings season is
really kicking off in a big way and this
CPI report really sets us up for a lot
of bullish momentum on the stock market
you're seeing those bond prices come
down which means bond prices are going
up oil prices coming back up that could
be something that you really are going
to want to watch for so stick with us
we'll be right back here 10 at 10 A.M
Monday morning on Market takes make sure
you don't miss it don't be a that's a
square don't do it and we also have of
course the retail sales report coming
out next Tuesday listen I am Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal no
you could have been anywhere else but
you're here with me and I appreciate
that we will be with you again next time